hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts towards a universal
influenza virus vaccine I'm Robert caste
alumnus of Labyrinth and I'll be a
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
wealth seminar presented by Lavery's
land roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars contributing to the
advancements of science there's a
content sharing capabilities lab roots
is a powerful advocate in implying
global networks and communities for more
information please visit lab rats comm
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the Greens Q&A button at the
top at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon and the lower right-hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem to the green Q&A button
lower left this is a educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
educational credits after the webinar is
over please click on the seee button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's guest speaker
dr. Peter police Peter police is
professor of microbiology and chair
department of microbiology at the Icahn
School of Medicine at Mount Sinai in New
York his research is in the area of RNA
and
viruses with special emphasis and
influenza viruses specifically he
established the first genetic Maps for
influenza A B and C viruses identified
the function of several viral genes and
defined the mechanism of neural nerman
days inhibitors he developed the field
of reverse genetics for negative strand
RNA viruses which allows the
introduction of site-specific mutations
into the genomes of these viruses this
technique is critical for the study of
the structural function relations of
viral genes for ingestible viral paths
on and for development of manufacturing
of novel vaccines at present police
groups works with Adolfo Garcia Sergei
and floran Kramer on the development of
a universal influenza virus vaccine Lisi
was a recipient of the Robert Koch Prize
in 2006 the recipients of the European
virology award in 2010 in recipient of
the 2012 san onofre institut pasteur
award an awardee of the 2015 burking
virology prize of the royal netherlands
Academy of Arts and Sciences police is a
member of the German National Academy of
Sciences the core assign member of the
Austrian Academy of Sciences and he is a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences a member of the National
Academy of Medicine and the fellow
American Academy of Arts and Sciences I
will now turn it over to dr. police
first presentation
this is Peter Pelosi I think we have
some problems I don't get the slides up
just one second
okay here we go we talked today about
pandemic influenza viruses in the past
and in the future
and what it means to really make and try
to get a universal influenza virus
vaccine when we talk about influenza and
particularly pandemic influenza meaning
pay an epidemic which has global
dimensions then we always have to think
of 1918 and what this slide shows us is
the life expectancy in the United States
from about 1900 to 2001 both female and
male and we see that in 1900 the average
life expectancy was barely over 45 years
47 years and then we see fortunately an
increase in life expectancy all the way
up to 2001 and if we are thinking about
the baby girl who won in 2016 we are
talking about a life expectancy of way
over 80 years the curve which we see
here however has one very remarkable
dick of about eleven years and that was
the result of the pandemic of 1918 1919
of influenza so this is a an event which
has historic dimensions the life
expectancy was reduced by about eleven
years and was in resort
authors influenza outbreak from about
November of 1918 to February of 1919 in
the United States we had about three
quarters of a million deaths and
worldwide we are thinking that maybe up
to about hundred million people died
during this pandemic of 1918 1919 it's
always is also sometimes with Theater's
influenza pandemic is the Spanish flu
and this had to do that Spain so this
was doing Riverrun and Spain was at the
time neutral and the only newspapers the
press could only report from these
neutral countries in Spain was the only
country at the time which had booted
about the influenza outbreak and that's
why it was called the Spanish flu but
that didn't mean there was no flu in
France or there was no flu in in the UK
testing contrary because these were
countries which were involved in World
War one and there was a lot of influence
in fact in terms of the u.s. involvement
more people died in the military of
influenza as compared to direct military
action so this is really something which
is quite dramatic and when we talk about
global epidemics pandemics of influenza
we sometimes really think about a virus
which was as dead as the 1918-1919
pandemic the next slide shows us in
electron micrograph and
was taken by a student of 92 and what we
can see here is a virus which has RNA to
segment the genome and we can see one
RNA in the center and then around others
one RNA segments there are seven other
RNAs which are making up the genome of
the influenza virus and then on the
outside around this RNA is lipid
membrane which is provided by the host
cell and then they are very importantly
in this lipid membrane we have inserted
the surface spikes which are referred to
as the hemagglutinin and we receive
their different subtypes in terms of the
h1 but is very sort of intimated already
we had about 18 different hemagglutinin
subtypes and then we have also the the
amenities and I showed here one of the
subtypes of the new mayonnaise is the
Hanwha so this is actually a virus it is
very very small if the computer in front
of you then it's maybe 20 inches 15
inches in diameter and a cell which gets
infected by it such an influenza virus
would be the size of the World Trade
Center the old World Trade Center or the
Empire State Building in New York City
and one of these virus particles can
infect the Empire State Building and
within about eight hours about hundred
thousand new virus particles have being
made and you can see that such a virus
replication such a burst of virus
replication can actually result in the
death of Fame think that's it so the
more one of the take-home messages of
what our discussion today is that there
is a lot of
variation there is a lot of genetic
variation of antigenic variation and in
terms of influenza viruses and the
important antigenic variation is on the
outside so again we are talking about
the hemagglutinin and we are talking
about the new many days which are the
surface proteins on the virus and that
is what our immune system is actually
recognizing and again a very important
point we are talking about extremely
variation genetic variation and that's
actually is the reason why we don't have
any good vaccine because there's a lot
of this variation going on and as you
probably know there are other viruses
which are similar in terms of others
genetic antigenic variation so this is a
dental grams of the lengths both of
these bars here all of these branches
will reflect the diversity of the
different viruses and on the Left we
have here the influenza virus diversity
of the hemagglutinin and this is shown
here and very importantly over self to
look at the ball which is telling us
what the degree of variability of
variation is and in this case it is 5%
so the length of this bar reflects it a
difference in 5% that if you look now at
the other diversity in terms of viral
proteins we Fe HIV and again you can see
here the diversity is quite dramatic if
you compare it to what we just discussed
before in terms of influencer in mid-may
where each a HIV is actually a little
bit less but clearly that is also one of
the reasons why we don't healthy the
vaccine against HIV because the virus is
constantly changing and
even within one patient that can't be
dramatic differences in terms of a sort
of the cloud of different HIV viruses
and then we also with on here the
hepatitis C virus ly protein the
diversity and again you can see here if
you just look at the bar again this is
five percent difference and one can see
here that the different variants of
hepatitis C virus in terms of the e
protein his also quite dramatic so this
is something we should be very much
aware that if you see for example we
have wonderful vaccine against measles
virus or measles and that has to do that
the virus doesn't change and we briefly
discussed like that is as we go wrong
now if we look at the diversity of the
influenza Rosenzweig not mean in more
detail we are just looking here we have
now a different ball here shows the 7%
diversity and in blue with the group
worm hemagglutinin and they are actually
now 18 different ones and then the F
group to hemagglutinin and there are six
of those in terms of human disease in
terms of human disease we have only seen
so far over the last hundred years we
are seeing age one we have seen humans
since 1918 h2 and we also have seen h3
so these are the only subtypes h1 h2 and
h3
which we as humans have seen over the
last hundred years now the epidemiology
of influenza viruses is quite
interesting it's complex so the next
slide shows actually the different
influenza viruses which are circulating
the human population and as I mentioned
before we have the 1918 and that was an
h1n1 virus and that we briefly discuss a
little bit what we know about the h1n1
virus and these viruses were present
from 1918 until 1957 and then we got
actually a new pandemic strain which is
referred to as age 2 and 2 in 1957 and
that was with us for 11 years so this is
a virus which has a different image
leutnant different from the h1 and
there's h2 virus with the different
urinators
and - were circulating for 11 years and
then in 1968 yet another pandemic strain
emerged and that actually it is h3n2
virus is still with us
now in 1977 another h1 virus another
h1n1 virus appeared and this one
actually is very similar to strains
which we are circulating in 1950 and
this is really a very surprising and
that Myers was with us for about from
1977 to 2009 and this virus was replaced
by would be referred to as a pandemic
h1n1 in 2009 so at the present time the
earth h3n2 viruses near Earth h1n1
pandemic h1n1 and we have influenza B
viruses in France OB viruses do not
occur in terms of these different
subtypes which we have seen with respect
to influenza A viruses but B viruses
also change and that is shown in the
changing color if you look at different
years you have slightly different colors
in terms of influence of beavers and
what this should illustrate is that we
can get
Riaan fixed it in about if you get
infected in 2016 for example in two or
three years the virus has changed
sufficiently that by 2019 probably can
get reinfected wasn't a prison influenza
virus because it has continuously
changed and that is referred to as
antigenic drift
whereas in terms of the influenza A
viruses when a new hemagglutinin such as
h2 or a new unit live in such a ch3
appears not open upon a new pandemic
strain and that is ruthless and the
genic shift now we already talked about
the 1918 situation and they we had quite
a lot of bases assert in terms of the o
the estimates are up two hundred million
people died in 1918 1919 in the US News
out the illustrates the severity of the
influenza pandemic pandemics and was a
death in terms of the United States as I
said we had about three-quarter million
in 1918 in 1957 this was a much milder
one this was the appearance of the H 210
for 70,000 the h3 was a milder in 1968
in the 2009 pandemic yet even milder
than that so this is quite important in
terms of the different influenza viruses
coming back to the 1918 one we I should
have mentioned before namely that the
bottom line shows that we don't have any
viable viruses from the period before
1933 and the 1918 virus is actually an
extinct virus however it was possible by
the bay his sequencing technology and
this was developed by jeffery
taubenberger who was at the time at the
Armed Forces Institute of Pathology
in Washington and he is now at the NIH
so by using material from soldiers who
died in 1918 the selections long block 3
if so those sort of translucent material
here is actually a paraffin block and
the dark material which we can see here
is material from the from the soldier
who died in 1918 and by using this
material and doing polymerase chain PCR
reaction sequencing it was possible by
Jeffery table to actually get the
sequence of this 1918 virus and with the
technology which we developed here at
Mount Sinai
it was then possible and they referred
to this technology is the worst genetics
because we are making a V so the RNA is
the actual genome which we talked about
if there are eight RNA segments which I
discussed before but then by using DNA
and transfecting putting into cells the
eight RNA segments in right here which
expressed the different RNA player
different RNA segments and then also in
terms of the protein expression plasmids
improve traction with these 12 plasmids
actually then resulted in the rescue of
these viruses and this was then paper
which was actually quite well received
The Lancet the the important British
Medical Journal selected is the paper of
the Year 2005 so more than 10 years ago
we were able to reconstruct the extinct
1918 Spanish influenza virus and
characterize it in terms of its
virulence and in terms of
different properties so we actually know
quite a lot about this virus now because
we have it in the laboratory we have to
work with as well as under special
conditions which are referred to is
biosafety level three conditions where
we can make sure that the virus does not
escape and does not cause any harm and
which is done under very careful
conditions so this is the story about
the 1918 Spanish influenza pandemic
virus which we they constructed in the
laboratory and very dumpy at the time
was he still at the CDC was able under
very stringent biosafety conditions to
get the first complete letters with with
all the eight genes from the 1918 virus
now we have talked about the different
influenza viruses which infect humans in
the end we have on the h1 h2 and h3 but
there are other viruses particularly
those which come from Birds avian
influenza viruses and they have been
shown to actually occasionally to infect
humans and so we have for example if we
look here H 5 and 6 in terms of the 2016
china this virus h 5 and 6 was
identified in china and we have also for
example in h7 right h5n1 which is shown
here this was a famous build layers we
do a little bit more about this but they
arose away h7 diff for different age 7
sexually we have 3 h 7 and 9 we have the
h 7 and 3 we have the page 7
and to Andrea if the age seven and seven
so you one can see that quite a lot of
these even in foreign services and they
have been shown to infect actually
occasionally humans this is something
which many people are worried about
particularly if we talk about the bird
flu this is the h5n1 virus and this
matters has actually caused a lot of
different the problems only in in the
Butley protein factories particularly in
China and we are actually very nervous
that this would be something which we
could jump into humans trying to move
forward so we have a slide here which
shows us the distribution of these a
avian influenza viruses and we can see
that in yellow that these alien
influenza viruses have been found in
very birds in poetry and is we can see
in terms of the correct squares there
were also h5n1 out cases in humans quite
a lot of people actually died as a
result of these infections the number of
cases is probably much much higher than
is being shown here because for the
w-h-o only recognizes cases which are
confirmed by laboratory that there had
mistakes here and they have to be
shipped to head of the US the saint of
the disease control over to the to
London and one cancer so they understand
that there are many more cases of
subclinical infections in these
different countries
whether it was Vietnam in China so it is
quite interesting that these h5n1 cases
have been recruited they are real
it is likely however that these are this
human cases are the result of large
doses which are inhaled by people
dealing with infected birds infected
chicken and so far there is no evidence
that the virus has been has been
transmitted from one rat from one person
to the other so these are very potential
new pandemic strains which might jump
into humans so what can we do against
these different influenza viruses and we
have actually two different classes of
fda-approved influenza virus works and
these are the so-called ion channel
blockers amantadine or 9:13 and these
are only effective against the e-type
virus is not the B viruses but but there
are also many resistant influenza virus
strains resistance against amantadine so
that the only rule works which we are
there are many days inhibitors and there
are two types and a media and also
family and they are effective against
both influence' Israel has influenza B
viruses so this is something which is
important and we should be aware all of
these different works which we have they
are probably underutilized in
particularly in cases of severe
influenza MERS infections we should
really think about these hantavirus
which are fairly safe versus and
represent a modality in out in terms of
trying to treat and also
prophylactically use them against
influenza virus infections
the second major sort of tool we have
against influenza has infections or
vaccines and that's sort of what I'm
going to highlight now starting with the
different types of influenza virus
vaccines which we have we have
inactivated influenza virus vaccine so
they are not inactive but these are
viruses which are grown up and then
inactivated by formaldehyde so that the
virus is not infectious any work but the
protein is actually when it is being
administered by injection it can
actually induce an immune response which
are which is protective there is also if
the approved attenuated influenza virus
vaccine which is given through the nose
intranasally and that is a lie flyers
but it is highly attenuated meaning very
very weak it barely replicates but it
actually can induce very good immune
response in the nose and in the upper
respiratory tract which is important
because it's a area the location where
the influenza virus is replicating and
then where recently a third class of
influenza virus vaccines has been FDA
approved and that is a recombinant
protein the hemagglutinin and that
protein is being made in baculovirus by
baculovirus insect cells and it is
injected also and this is a quite
effective vaccine against the
hemagglutinin and therefore against the
virus and particularly in terms of
people who have allergies against
egg products because both of the
inactivated hand the attenuated strains
are gone in amputated eggs the
recombinant one does not has never seen
alien cell and therefore people who are
allergic to alien proteins king of there
safely uses a competent influenza virus
vaccine now there are as everyone knows
the vaccines for influenza virus against
influenza virus are good however they
are underutilized and they are not
perfect they are not hundred percent and
that is one of the reasons why we are
looking for a better vaccine
specifically you have to understand that
I was mentioning before we have three
different influenza viruses circulating
at the present time we have h1n1 viruses
with h3n2 viruses and you have actually
two different kinds of influenza B virus
is circulated if you look at the names
for example if you look at B Chris pain
here that means it's a virus influenza A
virus isolate first in Brisbane and
isolate number 60 and in was actually in
2008 and as you can see in for the
influenza vaccine formulation for
2016-2017 the vaccine which we are going
to get starting in the fall has actually
four different components
unfortunately what again in h1n1 and
h3n2 and two different influence of D
virus components
now unfortunately the dismal ability in
the virus forces us to change the
vaccine formulation very often and this
slide here shows just look at the red
and the black this is from 2000 to 2010
we have an h1 and h3 and a B virus
component and the different years show
in red that devised for the vaccine had
to be changed from the previous year
saying
two out of three one out of three for
example in 2001 2002 have had to be
changed there's only one single year
which was in 2003 2004 there was no
change from the previous vaccine
formulation however there is for example
one year 2008 to 2009 they always say
components have to be changed so this is
something which is important and makes
it very difficult to manufacture
influenza virus vaccines because one has
to take into account the continuing
change which we have discussed before it
is also quite disturbing that in the
case of the 2009 the red curve shows
when dependent explain actually hit the
United States we had the majority of
influenza cases where in already in
October November and the new line shows
when the vaccine was actually shipped
and then it takes distribution sheet
from the manufacturers and then it had
to be distributed to pediatricians to
Walmart's pharmacies etc so one and then
it takes about 10 to 15 days until the
next scene really works so this is
really something quite dramatic in terms
of that something is included as a
pandemic strain we are not able to
really manufacture the vaccine strain
for the 2009 pandemic in sufficiently
fares so that it had food I had an
impact a positive impact or an impact in
terms of avoiding influenza fortunately
this pandemic levels of community very
mild and we actually sort of we so to
speak
lucky so now in
terms of the difficulties of the
vaccines one is they have to be changed
constantly in a new pandemic we are not
ready because it takes too long to
manufacture it and then also many times
the vaccine strain doesn't match the
circulating strain because the decision
of what kind of strain is actually added
to the vaccine is made about a year
before one actually vaccinate and
therefore many times the circulating
strains are not what we would like to
not match very well to the vaccine
strength and the vaccine efficacy is
actually lower so therefore the question
is how can we do better and the answer
to that is a universal influenza vaccine
one which will be effective against
different strains and against different
types and subtypes of the influenza
virus so what are we doing in the
laboratory and let me specifically see
right away the data I'm going to show
all in the laboratory so we do not have
a universal influenza virus vaccine at
this point but it should show us what we
can what we are thinking could be a
solution and the way we are doing this
is actually a collaboration between
three different laboratories at Mount
Sinai
this is Florian Kramer's laboratory at
Alta Casillas Auster's laboratory in my
own and so the idea is that we are
trying to make a vaccine against the
conserved region is important protein on
the outside of the virus and we found
that don't share the data but that the
there are two domains
we have to think about the membrane of
the viruses actually down here and the
hemagglutinin is sort of in seeded into
this membrane there about thousands of
these spikes per virus particle and we
store which is in green is actually very
much conserved but it is also not a very
immuno dominant in terms of the immune
response in contrast the head which is
shown here brownish color is actually
marine you know dominant it is simply
make more antibodies against it and
unfortunately it's also changing quite a
lot so this is what we are seeing in in
humans and we hope that a vaccine which
consists of the canary hemagglutinin
which has the same store as one we have
seen already but a different in opening
in terms of an h5 which we as humans
have never seen there is a hope that
such a vaccine which we induce an immune
response against the store and not much
against the age-wise because we have
never seen this so it's like being naive
towards this head and by then giving a
second vaccination with yet another
vaccine which in this case is a
different exotic head like in age six we
would hope that there is some
amplification of the b-cells against the
immuno sub-dominant stroke of the
hemagglutinin
and we would hope that a lot of these
antibodies against the against the stork
would then protect us in terms of
different strains belonging to a
one-handed loot mean if you remember
this
earlier slides we would like to make
also a vaccine against the group to
hemagglutinin israelis influenza B virus
tore component and so having those three
components who once taught a group to
store and an influenza B store we should
be able to actually make pay better
Maxine so this year again shows us that
we have a situation here now we are we
are going with into animals the animals
are in this case we are talking about
Mice and mice have never seen influenza
they are not a reservoir for the
infection and of influenza and we can
see we have to prime device with the DNA
and all we do is using here again
irrelevant health of the opening but
what is important this we have the we
are planning with a particular store and
then we are boosting with two different
vaccines again a different head with
canary cage six in the Chimera gage five
and then we challenge with a virus which
is higher the different from 1934 1947
2009 or even a completely different like
in h5 or even h 6h 6 hemagglutinin so
again by vaccinating in essence with a
vaccine that amplifies the conserved
regions of the hemagglutinin we hope
that we will make a the inducing humans
a vaccine which is quite protective and
this is shown here where we have again
some antibodies against the
if they come with the first neck seen we
get different head response but more in
terms of you stroke and yet more in
terms of slope after the second
vaccination with income at age five so
this is important which can show now
that in terms of the vaccination with
canary constructs is actually leading to
a protection we are using here in 1934
stock in in the mouse and became protect
against the virus which is that's almost
70 years later we get complete
protection we a challenge a challenge of
his master don't lose any weight the
black curve shows were happening
we have no vaccination and the control
is he'd light pink so this is sort of
showing us that over a long period of
time in mice we get complete protection
we can also show that we can protect in
this case against h5 challenge or it
should be in six challenge we can also
protect these mice with vaccine protocol
or approach strategy which I just
discussed so this is quite important we
are also able to show that this myself
the the base are protected against
different subtypes we can also show that
we can do similar experiments with a
group to stalk and we always are able to
show that the mechanism by which this
happens is through antibodies by a
passive transfer now there specifically
we showed that these parotid protective
stalk antibodies mediate the antiviral
activity by the mechanism by which the
antibody is actually let me show you
this here this is a model for optimal in
their induction of
my antibody dependent said that cell the
lytic cytotoxic mediated cell mediated
cytotoxicity ADCC antibody dependent
cell-mediated cytotoxicity and these are
effector cells near these antibodies
here is go against the stork and we
found actually very recently that by
having the interaction between the FC
portion of the hemagglutinin and the FC
receptor on effector cells and the
second contact point which is say like
acid of the effector cell and help of
the opening we get actually induced
antibody ADC antibody mediated
cell-mediated cytotoxicity and thought
this is a very interesting mechanism we
have at this point the nih has made
preparations of these new vaccines so
this is an h v gamma h v / + 1 and the
erosive purpose these are about 10,000
doses each in terms of the kinetic age 8
here and we hope that these kinds of
vaccine vaccines will be introduced into
the into humans and that we can measure
the immune response against such
vaccines and hopefully they are his
protective has to be able to show in
animals we have only shown this in mice
we have shown it in guinea pigs and we
have shown it in fluids but obviously
what is important is whether that kind
of mixing approach will also work in
humans
so in summary let me then sort of
repeater
highlight what I said we are trying to
make a universal influenza vaccine by
reducing the immuno dominance of the
immigrant minute and thereby increasing
the immunogenicity of the immigrants
talk and we have to remember that the
hemagglutinin head is really what
changes dramatically but this talk is
much more conservative and that if we
can sort of vaccinate against this
conserved domain we should be able to
make a immune response which would
protect us against many different
challenge strains and obviously these
are difficult vaccines they also have to
be long-lasting and also I haven't
really discussed this we also hope that
by this redirecting both in human
response from the head towards a store
we should also make better immune
responses against in your manna dey's
which is the second type of protein on
the surface of the virus and by having
candy bodies against in your many days
which is always a much more conserve
more conservative than the head of the
hemagglutinin we hope to make a very
efficient vaccine which should protect
us against all kinds of antigenic
variants including new pandemic strains
which will there is no doubt that such
viruses will procure in the future so
this is again this vision we have for a
human universal influenza vaccine again
we have not been in humans this is a
very long process but we hope that by
redirecting me again
the immune response away from the earth
by using irrelevant heads which we have
never seen we want to improve
the immune response against the stork of
the Americas 5:1 intermarriage 6:1 and
thereby protected against the different
variants Israelis different subtypes and
we believe that we need a group once
taught a group to store and those in
influence of evil store and again this
Israel which we are doing in a
collaboration fluent famous laboratory
hello Sofia solstice laboratory and my
own thank you very much and a method to
answer any questions presentation before
we get started on the question and
answer portion of the session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green to an a button at the lower left
of the presentation window and we're
gonna try to answer as many questions as
we can
and a first question for you doctor is
this was the difference in numbers of
death due from the h1n1 virus others due
to the vaccine that was not widely used
I'm eating or was it more due to the
advances in health care in general or
was the wrist hype and overstated by the
media it's probably the vaccine as I
said at the train wrecks me we have is
not perfect and the CDC actually said
that the live virus vaccine this year an
hour was not as effective what last year
really wasn't as effective as it should
be so there is that in terms of the life
virus vaccine into for last year and the
CDC is actually like
reminding the use of inactivated
vaccines we had in the years before
mismatches in terms of the h3 so that
was not optimal so clearly this is not a
perfect vaccine but I would still
strongly urge people to get vaccinated
it's the best thing we ever did say only
real in town and again we are working in
the laboratory to make better vaccines
but as long as we don't have that we
have to do we have to accept what we
have and there are pet other vaccines
and some of the press releases make us
believe
thank you very much doctor in H five and
one for example what do H and n signify
the h and the end are the hemagglutinin
and neuraminidase and those are the
glycoproteins on the surface of the
virus h5n1 was only found in innocence
in the in greatly there are some
occasional infections in humans but this
is not a virus which the h5n1 is not a
virus which is really easily
where is not related transmitted is not
not really is not translated from human
freedom so this is a I always say if you
are a chicken the h5n1 virus is very
dangerous but in humans so far we have
not seen transmission of h5n1
hemagglutinin subtype five new military
subtype one in humans from human to
another human
and thank you again and our next
question is are there any serious
adverse effects such as autonomic
dysfunction that have been seen after
the influenza vaccine
the influence of our vaccine is a very
very safe vaccine when people get a flu
shot and then they say two days later I
got the flu it is utterly impossible to
get influenza from an a from an
inactivated influenza virus vaccine
Revati there is no lie flyers people can
get to those later the flu but then they
were probably infected before they got
the vaccine and it certainly doesn't
have anything to do with the vaccine
again in contrast to what many sort of
internet sites tell us this influence of
our vaccine is extraordinarily poor safe
and we should not hesitate to take it
all righty thank you very much doctor so
we did have a couple more questions here
and if you would continue to submit
those questions she definitely would be
able to do so can you comment on the
mode of action of Timothy
question that me repeated what is the
mechanism of action of Tamiflu so this
is a neuraminidase inhibitor so it's an
inhibitor of the enzyme which is part of
the virus and it prevents the virus
actually from leaving infected cells so
this is a it work very very safe drug
it's many days inhibitor I briefly
mentioned the two classes of antivirals
we have human toe beans and angry health
illuminators inhibitors antennae flu is
a no mayonnaise inhibitor which is very
very safe it is given orally and it
prevents the spread of influenza viruses
from one cell to the other so when we
give the dog the patient takes at work
what happens is that the virus cannot
replicate Aires effectively as a
deterrent this project without the
inhibitor and it's a part which prevents
the effective spread from one infected
cell to the other that's a mechanism by
which Tamiflu in your minute ace
inhibitor works
thank you and what is it efficacy
percentage for one year range of the
current flu chasing in general
population and not
integration you are asking what the
efficacy of vaccines is is that correct
so the question was what is the efficacy
of influence of our actions as we
discussed today there are several
different influenza viruses circulating
at the present time there is h1 there is
h3 and there's influenza B and so the
current vaccine or is Oster death
components against H 1 against h3 but
also and unfortunately it's getting more
complicated there is a two components
against influenza B virus now what
happens is that some years who have more
B than a in some instances we have only
almost exclusively h3 so the vaccine can
have different efficacy against H 1
against h3 and B so there is no number
which is correct for every year
particular strain are different and it
also depends how you measure it for
example many vaccines prevent death but
people still get sick so if you are
measuring the efficacy of the vaccine in
terms of hospitalization and death the
vaccines are very very good but
sometimes next
are measured by is there any virus
demonstrable in the patient and then you
get lower values I would still say in
general a vaccines have an efficacy of
higher than 50% but there are some
exceptions and also it depends on the
age of the core worlds on the age of the
vaccinated people so there is no clear
answer to your very good and excellent
question but think about it is something
which is better then we have done
anything against HIV for example so
clearly not taking direction
particularly because it is so safe is
actually putting us at risk so the
vaccines are not perfect that they the
presently available vaccines are very
very good better than that reputation so
to speak and again the take-home message
is that they are trying to make better
vaccines in the lab but so far in the
nanotech for better vaccines in the
future but so far we have not there is
no vaccine higher universal vaccine on
the market and it need to take years
until this becomes fda-approved alright
thank you very much doctor and thank you
everyone for your amazing questions and
doctor do you have any final comments
before we close
but it is important to understand that
vaccines are really really good they are
very very safe and we would really like
to encourage people to think about
taking vaccines because even though they
are not perfect and we are working on
making them better they are very very
good and they are very very safe and
thank you very much doctor for those
closing remarks and I also want to thank
lab routes as well for the continuing
sponsorship today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing the
December 7th you will receive an email
from lab routes alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you